When you implement the OnLocationChange
callback, you can write the latitude and
longitude that you receive from
location services to your UI.
This is essentially the same as
in our old OncConnected method
before we switched to
continuous updates.
If you remember there we had
location.getLatitude that we
converted to a string
loaded into mLatitudeText.
And similarly location.getLongitude,
that we converted to a string and
loaded into an longitude text.
Now, we had done this previously in
On Connected so we would just get it
once whenever we connect, but now that
we're using the fuse location API and
we're requesting location updates from
that, those location updates will be
called back to us in the on
location change function.
And as a result,
we'll get continuous updates.